here's a question I get fairly often
which is how to have uncomfortable
conversations as you know I talk about
the importance of human skills cats
don't have to work very hard to be cats
it comes pretty naturally to them but
for us as human beings we actually have
to work very hard to be human and one of
those human skills that we need to
practice is how to have uncomfortable
conversations being uncomfortable is
part of being human and sometimes
discomfort is caused by something we
have with another person whether
professionally or personally there is a
tension that causes discomfort now there
are many ways to respond to that
discomfort we can run away from it that
is an option avoidance is always an
option I don't think it's the best
option because then it just perpetuates
the discomfort or breaks relationships
the better way to deal with it is to
lean into the tension now there are also
multiple ways to lean into tension if
you want to have a confrontation with
someone if you want to lean into that
tension and have an uncomfortable
conversation too often when we don't
have the skill set it gets worse and
explodes and becomes an argument and
sometimes also ends in a destroyed
relationship
so the skill of having an uncomfortable
conversation is essential this is how I
do them in fact I just had one recently
with a friend and it went like this I
need to have an uncomfortable
conversation with you
by by stating what's about to happen it
lets the person take a deep breath and
know what's about to happen is leaning
into tension it also lets them be
prepared and be a little less defensive
um if you don't trust your skills on how
to have an uncomfortable conversation
then say something like this I need to
have an uncomfortable conversation with
you I'm afraid of having this
conversation because I'm afraid that
I'll say the wrong thing or it'll come
out the wrong way and make things worse
so please be patient with me as I try to
Fumble through this and get out what I
need to tell you but it's more important
to me that I have this conversation with
you and try and address this situation
then avoid it because this relationship
matters to me and I want to go through
this with you
can we have that conversation and I
always do that I always ask permission
can we have that conversation can I have
this conversation with you now because
they may not be in the mindset forth
they may say yes I won't have this
conversation but can we have it in an
hour right so as opposed to being sprung
on them so I have to have enough I have
to have an uncomfortable I have to have
an uncomfortable conversation with you
can I have it now yes okay now you want
to engage in something called FBI it's
just a mnemonic you can do it in any
order but you have to have all three
your feelings
the behavior that made you that made you
feel that way and the potential impact
of the behavior doesn't change
be specific as you can feelings do
better than happy sad angry I'm really
frustrated or
um I was put on edge or I'm feeling
distant from you or I'm uncomfortable
because then label the behavior that
they did that made you feel that way and
again be really really specific avoid
things like you always dot dot dot
because they'll tell you the one time
that they didn't and now you're
backpedaling pick the most egregious or
the most recent one and talk about that
situation
and how whatever they did made you feel
a certain way and your fear that if that
continues over it's not goes unaddressed
that something will happen maybe you
know there'll always be tension between
us and the relationship will break and
that's exactly what I did with my friend
um it's a relatively new friend
something happened that made it
uncomfortable
um I said I need to have an
uncomfortable conversation with you
um just fumble through this with me I
don't wanna but this relationship
matters to me and so I want to have this
conversation I addressed what the
situation was
and then I said my fear is that if you
and I don't lean into this now that this
this this little French this friendship
this uh this sprouting of a friendship
that we're having will get destroyed and
I would actually rather see it grow
and we had a very uncomfortable
conversation and it turned out to be
fantastic because we ended up opening up
to each other and revealing various
insecurities and fears that were both
triggered by each other and it was just
fantastic and the relationship is even
better now than it was before so
please please please practice and learn
the skill of having uncomfortable
conversations and the way you're going
to practice them is by actually having
them